on monday march 1st this coming monday
longtime journalist ashley banfield
launches her own show
nationwide on news nation and ashley
joins us live this morning from new
haven connecticut to talk about what we
can expect
on this brand new program called
banfield ashley good morning thank you
for joining us
hey john thank you so much for having me
on your show i really appreciate this
well ashley tell us about this program
what we can expect
so you can expect a full hour with one
guest and a very deep dive and if you're
familiar with the larry king format
that is exactly what you're going to get
it's a chance to exhale
at 10 o'clock eastern at night when
you've been hearing news all day
and actually really peel back the layers
of the onion
and learn a lot about somebody who's
really
made it and is making the world go round
thought provokers
top you know thought leaders politicians
and celebrities
i'm going to sit down for a full hour
and let them do the talking and i'm
going to do a whole lot of listening
you know i think that's so important
ashley you know we all you've been
around long enough we've all done
interviews and
there's so there's always the condenser
there's a speed there's like a ticker in
the back of your head saying that his
interview has to be done at a certain
time
uh what kind of breath what kind of
space do you think you'll get by having
this kind of time to talk to someone
what viewers can take in from that
i think honestly what happens john is
that when you have a guest
who feels as though there's no rush then
that guest will often times
go out on a vein that you really want to
mine
and the luxury of not having that
20-second countdown in your ear is that
you go
where they go and then you learn things
i think one of the masters of
interviewing as well is howard stern
because he just goes wherever the guest
goes and so
the delight that i have after 33 years
of working in broadcasting
is no countdown i mean for an hour you
really can cover a lot of ground
so i'm thrilled to finally be able to do
that and then to actually have loads of
balance as well instead of like
polarized cable news echo chambers who
only you know have one political
philosophy or the other
i'm going to have it all absolutely well
we all look forward to it i'm a big fan
of
letting letting things breathe when
possible i wish we could let this
conversation breathe but we're just
about out of time ashley
good luck with the new program uh
banfield again it'll be on news nation
starting on monday weeknights at 10
o'clock thank you very much and again
good luck ashley
thank you john i appreciate it all right